Đây là công tyng mà làm học sinh lắm của em ăn nước ngủ khi ông khi sẽ ki một thân phúc được xin video này
sau em sẽ đi ngủ ngon và viết xử dụng này mang đi tình xe
Đây, công tyng này, một chân cũng có hiểu như xe ăn quan và là công tyng không hợp vẫn tốt
Mình khi ra đa trò và thông này sẽ thấy cho bạn một số nào khác
thì ra em lảo thệ 5 phút, trong bài tần nhau này để trụ các xe đi hiểu sau của công tyng này
và biết em trong nhau này vào các bạn nhá
Rồi, đầu tiên khi các bạn muốn hiểu với công tyng này các bạn có thể hiểu với những bính chất chuyển động trước
thì đầu tiên là việc bính tương đối của chuyển động
vì giúp thì là xem của autofl đăng chuyển động trên đường, như thế này
ở ngoài trọng, thì sẽ sẽ chỉ chuyển động ở tôn này của người lạnh xe
rất là người ngủ trong xe, đăng người ngủ ở bên đường, thì sao?
thì các bạn để thấy em có là đơn ra, đúng không?
ở là người...
đúng nhan, sau ở với lạnh xe, autofl đúng như thống người lạnh xe
của autofl đăng chuyển động, số người bên đường
đúng ra thì vì việc đó là trong một cái đứa cạnh như đây
có vật thì đúng nhan, sau ở bên này của vật để chuyển động, xuất vật kia
trên người ta sẽ có chuyển động của một vật, và tình tương đối
có rất không buốt nào, nó sẽ chính xam ở trong cả
sau bên người mà người chính xe
thì autofl đúng nhan, nhưng mà xam ở bên đường thì autofl đăng chuyển động
các bạn có thể thích tương đối là các bạn hãy quan sắc, thì quy đạo chuyển động của bão
với người đúng trên xe là sức và người đứng ở bên đường
thì nếu như mà người đúng trên xe lành, thì họ sẽ thấy có quy đạo
của bão sẽ có trạng là một đừng thạm và nhìn thấy ngá cho
nhưng vấn đề như người người người người người bên đường, thì lại thấy quy đạo
có trạng là đừng cầm, tình như vậy không chỉ chuyển động của tình tương đối
mà quy đạo chuyển động của tình tương đối
có là mọi bỏ có thể xam như là đừng nghiệm trong hệ quy triệu này
như là chuyển động, sau có hệ quy triệu khác
là sau đó chuyển động của tình tương đối
thì trong phần liên ở tàn làm, thì nào là phần liệu diễn được
cái tình tương đối đó của chuyển động
đó chỉ là cường tức cộm ở đâu
thì mình là các bạn để mới thấy những người định nghiệm đầu tiên
về hệ quy triệu đừng nghiệm trước
đây là hệ quy triệu gắn của em được vật làm góc
được quy đó là đừng nghiệm, quy dụ, xanh ra, là một vật đừng nghiệm
của ông, người quan sát, đừng cho mà đất của ông ở đừng nghiệm
và hệ quy triệu đồng, đi sau, đây là một hệ quy triệu gắn với một vật làm góc chuyển động
sau với hệ quy triệu đừng nghiệm, viết dụ, bao hòa, chuyển động sau ở sân ra
thì mình có thể gắn tổ hòa là hệ quy triệu đồng
ở nhà, giòn nước đăng choi sau với người đừng nghiệm
ai, hoặc chỉ sẽ khách chuyển động trên đường
thì đây cũng là những các vật chuyển động
thì mình sẽ gắn nó với hệ quy triệu chuyển động
thì tôi đó, các bạn này có muin tất, để quản thân,
mình cứ 1 2 1 3 2 3, mà tôi có muin tất, đối với các bạn
thì mình có thể chọn, hệ quy triệu đồng nó sẽ khách lại kè
ở đây cũng là một vật chuyển động
và hệ quy triệu đồng nghiệm, cho nó mà đất
ở hòa, khoảng 30 kè bên đường, ở nhà, chỉ mấy đường dạ như vậy thôi
ok, rồi, cho các bạn toàn lên qua này, mình lại còn thấy không
để làm một hòa, đầu qua nhà, thì là tạo đăng chuyển động
từng lúc của các người đang xí chuyển
thì nếu như mình mà mình cho tụi hệ, là người đe步, ở hòa, thì hệ quy triệu chuyển động sẽ đảo
thì thông thư ở đây là tạo đăng chuyển động sẽ đảo, và một vật chuyển động sẽ đảo
thì mình sẽ thuê nó, ở đây là cá nô, thì mình sẽ sẽ mấy nó, ở đây là chuyển động sẽ đảo
đối với 2, sẽ đảo để hệ quy triệu đồng, thì nó sẽ đảo nó
đồng, ở đây, xong các bạn có thể thuê nó, thì mình qua xong, một đồng, cũng sẽ có tốt đồng nó
là vật xong, là vật xong, là hệ quy triệu đồng ít, là chứ
thông thường mình sẽ đảo xong, đối với 2, và các liền hệ quy triệu đồng ít
thì xong, các khi đó, các bạn có thức của vui 1 2, về 1 2, về 1 2, và mình hay bà,
ở đây, mình giúp theo các bạn này, mình một người chào tuyền và mọi người xong vụ 1 xong email,
muốn cho tuyền dì về hướng ổn à bê, cái hóa nha, rất là bề 1 2, và đốc,
rất là ạ, rồi, xong bế tối, ở đây, của chí trposition đồng, xong bến, ấy ạ,
ở đây, thì chúng ta phải cho các bạn trong quốc, vàòng trên đốc xong email 8,
ở đây của chí trposition đồng này, mấy 1 2, đi theo hướng ả xe, Puis khi đó các bạn phê 1, bật mà,
Vì vui một hài lên hoang, nó sẽ bà nhớ.
Tạng ở trong đây bố lắm được.
Vì chào, rồi, tìm khi đó mình chọn,
và thái ổ tốt, khi kế, và tốt, ổ tốt.
Chính là thì các bạn là vế, hay bà.
Vế hay bà thì đi từ hướng thì thắng đứng nhé.
Vì chào, ở đi từ hướng năm ngang nhé.
Đôi, đúng tôi đã có một hộ như đối khoảng 1 tên này này,
là đúng khẩm hộ tuy táy mình hài,
sao rọng lắm được không?
Thằng Wie Mù Bá, đúng, trong nguyênu, سuôi mà Đất,
Dù thị là đúng không?
Mù tổ gùm một xong là trẻ nắm 흥 Đấy.
Vì chào, và tốt là chỉ ổ thị là bà trong hàng kênh này đúng.
Đúng không?
Trì. Vì bà có bà, tìm bà còn về bà,
tốt không thường hậu này.
Cần biết các ý như mức lúc tấuμ như bà,
Thế sẽ có thể nào được Bai
Nhưng có lâu, tìm cũng như like
Sẽ we all này về chỗ bạn đẹp của mình
Để của tình hiểu só hơn
Vậy thì cũng tương này nha
Vậy cũng có thể nào mà mình ăn khi lâu biết thì có thể nhanh tín trực tiếp nó thấy
Để của tìm học, mình lại trong lâu biết
Thì có thể kìa kàng, bài bản hơn nữa
Nha